hello everybody markiplier here back
from the trip to insane land that I went
through just a little bit ago
I gotta backtrack a bit and hopefully
cuckoo-land that guy's just gonna go so
I just have to make sure that I never
ever ever ever ever ever ever die hard
[Music]
I still technically have to go the same
place I was before are you doing it look
kid have you been jazzers I think I'm
creeping up on you this
[Music]
I don't know why but the Justine music
is so much scarier than anything that's
been in Indonesia the the original
amnesia it's just I don't know like
probably made in a few days either way
it's just flippin fantastic okay yeah
and then don't hide from people like you
that you can't see me I got a chair
watch that oh you're scary no no I don't
think that's it that couldn't be it at
all but this next parts gonna be this is
the part where I can hot die or else
that music will come back to haunt me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me oh this is that good you look very
quickly oh don't tell me don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me don't kill me
please anything but death oh and by the
way this is a bug I tried to use those
coins but I can't use them anymore
they're just showing up thank you
[Music]
well I'm a big baby
you still here
Oh
it's still there what am I supposed to
do go away why they don't leave me alone
god I really am a big baby
that guy can't one shot
[Music]
not that way I'm not gonna go that way
finally back to where I need to be
surprising and listen total sanity you
can actually hear how sane I am why
didn't this music started when I got
okay now I'm gonna carefully actually
look through these make sure we'll do
this section there are no books this
section there are no polar Bull books
back wall ooh
oh no no pull of all books none none
none
I'm just eliminating so I don't have to
come back because I know definitively
that there are none here none here and
none here and one there this one that
may have been the elusive one I'm not
sure maybe I did okay none none none go
clunk Wow
give me stop shaking me around I'm not
one to be trifled with okay none none
none 100 Thank You that then I think
that what's the addition of the one
upstairs which is on the back wall right
there I think this is it because I
remember I only pulled four beforehand
it's amazing what you can do when you
can think clearly oh it's just amazing
the progress that can be made nope the
end is near
I can feel nice so slowly leaving leaves
my body even though I have more than ten
health form is working for me no one
found the potion for me I am not sure
what will happen when I died there's no
arrow thrown what will happen to my
little principality well I shouldn't
waste my last time we're thinking about
things like that I should rather help
poor people with shelter in the food to
make sure that I will come to heaven
okay yeah do that and not whatever the
hell happened here
I'm okay
I did not I did not think the
teleporting naked guys gotten to me that
much anyone can just forget that that
ever happened we're good
what happened got it good job I got a
key to another bedroom somewhere don't
know where oh wait yes I do I think I
remembered in the blurred moments of my
insanity prior there was another bedroom
door over this way Johannes his bedroom
[Music]
is that no no I was over here it was
where I heard that evil noise no not
there it's over this way alright I was
so not ready for that I was beyond not
ready for that that's right okay let's
see here
I killed your servant is that could am I
getting close to the ending I feel like
I might be it got dark it got real dark
[Music]
painting is off filter filter but
there's nothing in it here no chair lava
lamp flash Lady Bob this guy lived in
cramped quarters there's nothing here
what the hell is this this is new kind
of weird stuff going on here
my analysis in one Alice in Wonderland
because things are taking on weird shape
I am I'm a little concerned for my
safety what is going on
okay well things are definitely getting
unique I'll give it that
[Music]
okay now where am I
what Oh killed all these statues and how
can I shake their hand
ah no sorry I'm them in haha sorry about
that I'm gonna just go away now
[Music]
I'll go visit I'm assuming that's
Johanneson I'll go visit them in a
second
right now who knows what interesting
doodads might be in here that don't need
me to go into that Roma career to make a
flow to God
alright fine I'll go in this might be
the end of the custom story here so
let's go stab him
who are you I am mark what are you doing
here I'm here to kill you Vincent
who is this man are you here to hurt me
I'm Johanna's the boo-boo-boo the lord
of all start why do you come here is it
because of Vincent's victims I had
nothing to do with that and didn't even
know what he was doing to all of these
people I swear
just walk away and leave me alone it's
better for you to not get you drunk
don't tell me what to do nobody tells me
what to do privacy for this this will to
this kingdom it's an empty show I'm
gonna keep this all in one episode of
it's really big
ah much better look look at those
realistic looking cows looks so good in
what not totally not raising bulls it's
locked I need to find a key
[Music]
freedom oh I'm assuming I made the right
choices
oh thank you so much
Forrest the guy who made the game and
you are a good custom story bigger
I think Morris also made tenebrous Lake
this is another extremely good one you
can find it somewhere maybe in the last
screen I don't know find it here so
thank you so much
Boris slave trade would ya thank you
guys so much this is awesome the new
lantern was cool so thank you guys so
much watching oh and take your booty pie
back okay everybody thank you guys so
much for watching and just I love these
huge custom swords they're so great and
everything that they like oh wow for the
community to do more content to chew on
as Sobers up let people take the time to
make these so Thank You Boris thank you
everybody for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
[Music]
Oh